d'ailleurs je je je ne cesse de le dire
je ne suis pas scientifique je ne suis
qu'un passeur je suis à la croiser des
chemins mon nom s'oubliera celui des
scientifiques dont je parle non
benonjami ça fait 30 ans que tu nous
apprends des
choses donc est-ce que d'après toi la
science est un puissant fond est-ce
qu'on pourra faire ça éternellement ou
pas alors je l'espère Michel Dr de la
science non non je ne dis pas que moi je
pourrait le faire
pendant encore 30 ou 40 ans why not mais
assurément oui la science est un
puissant fond en fait ce qui ce qui
m'interroge et m'excite moi quand quand
je vois des des sujets comme les tiensou
comme d'autres vulgarisateurs c'est que
je m'aperçois que la science elle
découvre mais que une fois qu'on
s'intéresse à ça on se rend compte aussi
qu'elle complète ou qu'elle corrige ou
qu'elle affine c'est ça qui est
intéressant la science n'est jamais
définie tive c'estàdire que une
découverte en entraîne obligatoirement
une autre et et alors ça c'est le job
des scientifiques mais quand on est
vulgarisateur comme nous sommes un peu
et bien on ressent aussi un peu ces
chosesl c'estire que sans avoir une
formation scientifique sur tel ou tel
sujet quand on commence à s'intéresser à
un sujet et bien on on on est un petit
peu dans l'état dans l'état du
découvreur parce qu' l'on apprend on
comprend et
allement ça nous invite à aller chercher
un peu plus loin et se dire ce que j'ai
appris toutes ces C ces ces informations
qui me permettent de m'épanouir et que
je vais transmettre et bien j'ai envie
d'en savoir et d'en dire un peu plus
pour prolonger cet épanouissement chez
le le le téléspectateur l'auditeur
est-ce que ce qui t'excite le plus
peut-être c'est pas ça du tout il
corrige-moi j'ai l'impression que le
moment où toi tu décou couvre que ça t'a
fait des petits pop-corn dans le cerveau
tu as envie que les autres ils vivent
cette sensation est-ce que c'est l'une
de tes motivations c'est exactement ça
la première la première des choses c'est
ça c'est le fait d'avoir compris et et
il y a une c'est c'est c'est jubilatoire
de comprendre hein c'est cette fameuse
image qu'on a toujours représenté c'est
c'est c'est archimère dans sa veille
noire avec c'est le le Eka voilà ce
petit moment c'est c'est c'est c'est je
sais pas ce qui se passe dans le cerveau
à ce moment-là
tu le sais mieux que moi mais il y a une
forme de de de pétillement effectivement
c'est c'est le pop-corn et et et ce truc
on a envie de le partager al pourquoi on
a envie de le partager peut-être aussi
parce que on a envie de faire prolonger
ce moment-l parce que au moment ENF moi
je sais que
personnellement j'éprouve cette
sensation au moment où je comprend et je
l'éprouve une deuxième fois c'est le
deuxième effet qui se coule il va dans
l'œil de l'autre quand je trouve les
mots pour le dire incroyable en fait
comment je vais le raconter pour
transmettre cette émotion oui pour du
coup aussi peut-être intéresser
quelqu'un un sujet qui de primeabord est
censé ne pas l'intéresser ça ça veut
dire que tu as vraiment trouvé les bon
mot complètement parce que c'est un
petit peu ce que j'ai
ressenti quand j'apprends quand je
comprends quelque chose bah évidemment
si je l'apprends et je le comprends ça
veut dire que auparavant je ne m'y étais
pas intéressé voilà donc euh bah
j'essaie de faire revivre ce moment-là
euh justement à tous ceux qui qui nous
lisent nous regardent nous écoutent
alors en fait ce que çaactive dans le
cerveau c'est le circuit de la
récompense donc ça c'est chouette parce
que ça ça libère des hormones comme la
dopamine par exemple qui nous font très
très plaisir ça ça m'emmène sur une
autre question moi j'ai vécu des
douleurs parce que je me suis pas
considéré comme vulgarisateur je l'ai
compris une fois que j'ai compris que ce
que je disais toucher une audience large
oou j'ai décidé de prendre un peu de
responsabilité dans ma manière de faire
et à ce moment-là je me suis rendu
compte que la science ayant évolué il y
a des choses que je pensais vrai et qui
étaient vrais au moment où je les ai
apprises qui sont devenu pas tout à fait
vrais oui je me suis rendu compte que il
fallait que je corrige des choses que
j'avais dit dans le temps j'ai mis je
pense une année à admettre que c'est
quand même beaucoup de monde qui dit que
je me trompe et peut-être temps que je
lise des études un peu plus récentes sur
tel et tel sujet et là autant d'habitude
ça active le circuit de la récompense là
il a fallu que j'active autre chose dans
la remise en question est-ce que toi tu
as vécu comme ça des douleurs de devoir
te mettre à jour où c'était quelque
chose de très clair pour toi et et au
contraire quoi tu aimes bien absorber
pour pouvoir affiner le le savoir
général qui existe alors en fait ça fait
partie de ma formation de base moi j'ai
une formation de journaliste au départ
le le journaliste mais comme le
vulgarisateur est un est un passeur au
départ alors évidemment aujourd'hui il y
a des journalistes éditorialiste mais à
la
base mon rôle notre rôle de de de de
journaliste c'est de regarder d'observer
et puis ensuite de transmettre
d'expliquer voilà sorte de de trait
d'union et donc fatalement ce que l'on
observe évolue avec le temps toute
discipline confondue et y compris dans
la science donc deux choses peuvent se
produire ou bien on commet une erreur
quand on fait une explication et je me
souviens d'en avoir commise plutôt des
petites hein parce que on on on oui la
pomme tombe pas très loin du Pomier quoi
voà on a quand même toujours quand quand
on bosse sur un sujet on on vérifie on
croise les informations pas que dans les
bouquins pas que sur les sites internet
on appelle des experts et dès qu'on a un
doute et bien ça devient une hypothèse
et et non pas une t voilà une vérité
absolue donc voilà on on prend on prend
toutes ces toutes ces précautions pour
autant parfois il y a des des des
erreurs qui se qui se glissent je me
souviens d'erreurs dans dans dans la
nomenclature notamment la première fois
que j'ai représenté des des des atomes
d'oxygène et bien bêtement je les ai
représenté en bleu alors que l'oxygène
c'est rouge bon quand on fin comme
celle-ci on on on on s'excuse on la
corrige et puis bon on évite de la
refaireou surtout qu'on est pas sur une
erreur du sens fondamental on est sur
une erreur d'étiquetage alors ça veut
pas dire qu' faut pas faire attention
mais effectivement tu as pas raconter
n'importe quoi non plussolument et puis
il y a des choses qui évoluent moi je je
me souvien de de la manière dont on
expliquait le le le vol la la la la
portance il y a 25 ans c'est plus du
tout la même manière aujourd'hui j'ai
corrigé aussi alors ce qui est délicat
c'est que comme les vidéos sont euh sur
Internet vidéo elle elle date parfois on
dit ah Jamie il a fait une erreur il
explique t regardez la vidéo elle a été
tournée en 1996 voilà mais regardez
celle que j'ai tourné en en en
2000 en 2019 ou ou en 2020 et là
j'explique le phénomène différem oui non
mais tu as raison parce que maintenant
comme ce savoir là il est fixé quelque
part on peut on peut avoir cette
impression de et et l'espace commentaire
est fait pour ça de dire mais qu'est-ce
qu'il raconte bah il raconte quelque
chose qui est vrai quand on remet dans
le contexte temporel tout à fait mais et
d'ailleurs ça m'amène à une réflexion
c'est quand on est lecteur quand on
s'intéresse à un sujet il faut toujours
s'intéresser au contexte dans lequel il
a été écrit de regarder la date écrit ou
ou ou ou réaliser quand il s'agit d'un
documentaire toujours regarder dans quel
contexte il a été écrit pour avoir
conscience de l'état de la connaissance
au moment où ça a été réalisé je crois
que pour réenchanter la science il faut
faire un peu plus d'histoire des
sciences pour la rendre un peu plus sexy
comme dit euh ettienne clin pour la
rendre un peu plus sexy il faut faire un
peu plus d'histoire des sciences et
quand on fait de l'histoire des sciences
ce qui est passionnant c'est que que il
faut se replonger dans le contexte
aujourd'hui euh finalement on sait plein
de choses tout un chacun nous savons
plein de choses qui sont évidentes mais
quand on se replonge dans le contexte
dans lequel étaient les premiers
découvreurs on savait rien les
découvertes sont encore plus exaltantes
plus enthousiasmantes parce qu'on ne
savait rien mais en même temps elles
sont extrêmement difficiles à dire quand
on relit par exemple le le le Darwin le
le le Discours sur l'origine des espèces
on voit toutes les précautions qu'il
prend pour expliquer l'évolution c'est
c'est çaen est même presque résible
parce que parce que on se dit mais mais
mais va droite au but he mais non il
peut pas aller droite au but parce que
dans dans opposition y a il y a dans la
culture générale ce qu'il met en avant
n'existe pas à à à un pouillemme de ce
qu'il va exister n'existe pas n'est pas
présent dans dans dans dans le cerveau
du public il y va à petit pas pour
éviter de choquer pour faire en sorte
que les gens comprennent bien tu vois et
il explique en en 200 pages ce qui te
ad en 25 liges ou comment toi tu as
atterri dans l'émission C'est pas
sorcier on va être obligé d'en parler un
petit peu en fait bon moi je l'ai dit
oui j'ai une formation de de de de
journaliste je ne voulais pas faire de
télé quand j'étais quand j'étais
étudiant en école de journalisme j'étais
passionné par la radio par l'écrit et
voilà ça me semblait beaucoup plus
simple ça l'était d'ailleurs mais tu
voulais pas incarner du coup au départ
non non non et pendant pendant 7 8 ans
j'étais derrière la caméra j'étais Jerri
journaliste reporter d'age j'ai vu des
vidéos de toi avec des gros gués puis
que j'entends simplement ta voix dans
ces vidéoouou donc donc je je je ne
voulais pas être devant la caméra parce
que ce qui m'intéressait d'abord et
avant tout c'était d'aller chercher
l'information puis ensuite de la mettre
en forme mais la mettre en forme pour la
la radio ou pour pour l'écrit le fait
d'être devant la caméra je trouvais que
c'était une contrainte supplémentaire
qui me semblait-il prenez le dessus par
rapport au au aux deux phases
précédentes qui pour moi sont
essentielles la présentation nétant que
la ceriss sur le gâteau voilà et puis et
puis il y a des hasards voilà je
travaillais avec Fred il s'est retrouvé
présentateur d'une émission de Scien il
m'a demandé à l'époque d'être
journaliste de bosser avec lui mais en
tant que journaliste et puis l'année
suivante
l'émission continuait il m'a dit mais tu
veux pas venir présenter une petite
rubrique avec moi sur sur des bouquins
des trucs étonnants j'y suis allé puis
on a présenté cette émission tous les
deux à la fin de chaque émission on se
disait mais est-ce qu'on est vraiment
sûr d'en avoir d'avoir compris le sujet
que l'on venait de traiter et ça
commencé comme ça par des petits trucs
comme ça et puis on a on a on a écrit le
concept de de de C pass sorcier en
pensant euh que ça durerait deux trois
saisons voilà oui on se dit jamais je
vais écrire un truc qui va avoir un
succès incroyable surtout pas surtout
pas c'est que moi j'ai en plus à ce
moment-là j'avais très très envie de
reprendre ma caméra en plus et et de de
de repartir euh tourner courir le monde
et et et tourner avec ma caméra et donc
quand il s'ag il s'est agit de de de
répartir les rôles qui seraient dehors
qui serait dans le camion et tout bon
moi j'ai je t'avoue que expliquer euh
c'est un truc que j'aime bien faire donc
le camion me plaisait et en plus comme
j'allais être papa je me disais bon
allez je vais je vais voir ça fait poser
les valises voilà j'ai posé un peu mes
valises et mais je pensais pas les poser
pendant 19 ans 19 ans voilà c'est
incroyable voilà c'est incroyable la
première émission elle a été diffusée en
94 comment elle était traitée justement
la science à la télévision à l'époque
parce que j'ai j'ai j'ai c'est une
question très orientée
maisement que ce que vous avez vécu en
mode estce qu'on a compris la flottaison
du sous-marin c'était pas une question
qu'on se posait à l'époque de est-ce que
les gens ont vraiment compris et j'ai
j'ai presque l'impression que s'il y
avait pas des gros termes techniques on
se disait c'est des rigolo quoi c'est
exactement ça ok dire que la science
était sur un piédestal quand on
interrogeait un
scientifique bah plus il disait des mots
compliqués Mo on comprenait plus il
devait être sérieux plus il était
scientifique ou c'est ça et et et je
pense que dans la tête des gens quand
les gens échangeaient entre eux c'était
oh là là tu as vu il lit des choses j'ai
rien compris mais voilà parce que
c'était l'image que l'on se faisait du
scientifique le scientifique représenté
en blouse blanche avec des des lunettes
cerclé de fer derrière un tableau noir
avec de la crisse c'était l'image que
l'on faisait que l'on se faisait la
science alors elle avait déjà commencé
un peu à à évoluer hein parce qu'il y a
il y a eu des précurseurs après traiter
ces sujetsl sous forme de de de de
magazine dans la longueur et puis sans
se prendre au sérieux ouais parce que
c'était ça aussi et et et et pourquoi on
a eu envie de faire l'émission comme ça
c'est que d'ailleurs le titre le dit
bien c'est dire que à un moment donné on
se rendait compte euh avec Fred que que
quand on on on s'intéresser à sujet à un
sujet qu' commençit à gratter ben ce qui
semblait compliqué si on prenait le
temps de de de de de gratter de
comprendre de poser les bonnes questions
de ne jamais lâcher quand on pose une
question à un scientifique de dire
attendez j'ai pas compris recommencer
qu'est-ce que vous voulait dire par là
de d'aller jusqu'au bout de de ne pas
tendre un micro complaisant avec une
phrase qui va être être incompréhensible
sauf pour une communauté de de
scientifiques et bien si on fait ce
travail làà et bien le sujet peut être
compris peut être accessible quand on
dit c'est pas sorcier quand on voyait ce
gros camion qui partait à l'aventure
voilà c'était aussi montré que Ben la
science c'est pas que dans des labos un
peu poussiéreux un peu triste que ça
peut être très épanouissant de
l'enrichissement ce titre c'est pas
sorcier parce que là on l'entend plus
dans son sens propre parce qu'on le
connait en tant que marque presque ouais
mais c'est pas sorcier c'était en 94
c'était fort de dire ça c'est vraiment
n'ai pas peur c'est pas compliqué hein
ou et et d'ailleurs quand tu me posais
la question quelle était l'image de la
science à l'époque quand on a fait ces
passionci il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disaient c'est pas sérieux ouais voilà
ouais ouais donc parce que effectivement
on on on présentait les choses de
manière totalement ça ça correspondait
pas au code de l'époque et parce que ce
que je trouve formidable dans le fond je
sais pas si vous si vous l'avez
conscientisé comme ça mais il y avait un
côté on va pas vous rendre expert de
quoi que ce soit vous allez juste
comprendre les fondamentaux qu' a besoin
pour appréhender cette connaissance
c'est ça c'était ça le but du jeu
c'était on vous donne les clés on ne
formule pas une opinion on vous on ne va
pas vous dire si le nucléaire c'est bien
ou si c'est mal on ne va pas vous dire
si les OGM c'est bien ou si c'est mal
non on va vous donner des clés pour que
vous vous fassiez votre propre opinion
je pense que vous avez été aussi opposé
à certaines difficultés ou pas mais
j'imagine que dans ces démarches là au
départ le fait de faire intervenir des
personnes scientifiques en leur disant
sois clair donc ne sois pas exhaustif ça
devait être douloureux pour eux parce
que vis-à-vis des autres personnes qui
pouvaient les voir allit peut-être les
juger parce qu'ils avaient pas donné
tous les points de détail surtout
partout oui mais oui et non parce qu'en
même temps on a on allait chercher des
des des intervenants qui étaient les
plus accessibles possible et puis
c'était une époque aussi où on va dire
allez il y avait un panel de
scientifiques qu'on VO est tout le temps
à la télévision pour tel ou tel sujet
souvent nous on n demandait on nous
demandait d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
avez un cons conseil scientifique pour
l'émission non on n pas de conseil
scientifique en fait les scientifiques
qui intervenaient et c'est toujours vrai
aujourd'hui hein dans dans le monde de
Jamie ou dans ce que l'on fait sur
épicurieux il y a pas de conseil
scientifique en revanche on va trouver
le scientifique qui a la réponse à notre
question ça c'est du journalisme voilà
dans l'équipe on avait un un un médecin
un médecin journaliste quand il faisait
une émission euh je sais pas moi sur le
moteur à 4 temps sur l'eau c'était
parfait il y avait pas de problème mais
dès qu'il touchait un sujet médical
alors là ça devenait habitable pourquoi
parce que systématiquement il nous
disait oui mais il pensait au regard de
sa communauté c'est ça ou mais je peux
pas dire les choses comme ça ben si
parce que parce que donc du coup c'est
pas lui qui faisait les é tous sauf le
médical du coup c'est incroyable he voà
toi tu as passé un bac L oui école de
journalisme tu as traité de la science
ensuite toute ta vie cette passion
dévorante est-ce que tu as déjà eu le
syndrome de l'imposteur de te dire il me
manque un truc qui me rende légitime à
faire ce que je fais ou ou pas du tout
si si je l'ai en permanence incroyable
je l'ai en permanence parce que euh
d'ailleurs je je je ne cesse de le dire
je ne suis pas scientifique je ne suis
qu'un passeur je suis à la croisée des
chemins mon nom s'oubliera celui des
scientifiques dont je parle non est
arrivé de recevoir des prix mais à
chaque fois quand on me dit vous allez
all recevoir ce prix et bien se pose la
question de la légitimité suis-je
légitime pour recevoir ce prix je n'ai
fait que mon métier hein rien de plus
rien de plus je me la pose même après
toutes ces années c'estou même après
toutes ces années oui j'ai j'ai toujours
du mal à expliquer quelque chose sans
sans m'appuyer sur des
références et très souvent je reçois des
des des invitations pour faire une
conférence sur tel ou tel sujet je dis
mais non c'est pas moi qu'il faut
inviter moi je ne suis pas un expert de
cette question à la limite pour
interviewer l'expert oui je décline très
souvent ok je comprends très très
souvent mais mais c'est ce mot imposture
qui fait peur oui c'est ce mot donc
toujours toujours dire que je ne suis
qu'un passeur voilà pour éviter
l'imposture c'est pas mon interview mais
je vais raconter une anecdote très
rapide j'avais beaucoup discuté avec
Sylvie chocron qui est dans un domaine
de Scien
qui m'intéresse et je lui faisais part
de ça et et elle avait eu des mots
réconfortants en me disant mais merci de
rendre digeste une partie de notre
travail et cette phrase elle elle tourne
encore un boucle où je me dis voilà ça
peut être juste ça moi mon métier par
exemple rendre digeste une partie du
travail de précision je reviens sur ces
pas sorciers c'était très nouveau
effectivement d'avoir un animateur dans
un dans un studio en l'occurrence le
camion et une autre sur sur le terrain
ça aussi vous l'avez décidé consciemment
très rapidement que ça allait donner une
dynamique à l'émission d'avoir quelqu'un
qui nous emmène comme un journaliste et
une autre qui est au QG et qui prend le
temps de nous expliquer c'était ça alors
ça c'est arrivé tout de suite ok dès le
début ça a été alors c'est pas nouveau
mais c'est une technique qui qui a qui a
fait ses preuves dès qu'on a pensé à ce
concept on s'est dit voilà comment ça
doit ça doit fonctionner la science ça
commence avec de l'observation et
ensuite une explication le terrain la
paillasse après après l'idée géniale et
c'est le troème 3è auteur de de
l'émission Bernard Gonner qui a eu
l'idée du camion se dire mais cette
paillasse ce labo qu'est-ce que c'est où
est-ce qu' où est-ce qu'il est tu vois
et le fait d'avoir je pense apporté une
dimension très très importante le fait
d'avoir eu l'idée du
camion bah c'était l'idée de de partir à
la découverte aller ailleurs et ça
c'était super important parce que pour
montrer que que bah la science elle elle
ne se passe pas que dans des Labau
commence d'abord sur le terrain et qu'il
faut aller vers les phénomènes euh et
non pas rester renfermé c'est vrai en
toute chose pas que la science voilà ne
pas rester coincé à l'endroit où l'on
vit bouger aller voir ailleurs pour
comprendre ce qui se passe ou et en même
temps c'était accrochant aussi je pense
le camion parce que ben tu vois moi de
mon plus jeune âge un camion je sais ce
que c'est h une paillasse de la beau je
savais pas ce que c'était oui dans ce
que tu appelles la paillasse pour le
coup là peu de tube à ESS beaucoup de
maquettes oui alors la grande question
que tout le monde se pose est-ce que
c'est Jamie qui préparer ses maquettes
le soir dans son coin alors c'est pas
moi qui les fabriquait
euh au début je l'ai je les dessinais
alors je dessinis je suis très mauvais
en dessin mais je dessinais des crobars
des crobars en disant parce que ce qui
était important c'était et ça l'est
toujours quand on fait une explication
c'est de se dire qu'est-ce que je veux
montrer précis
donc déjà pour savoir ce que l'on veut
montrer précisément il faut avoir une
très bonne idée du concept c'est là où
il est important de contacter les
experts pour bien comprendre les choses
quand on les a bien compris et ben on se
dit attends il me faudrait une maquette
qui fasse C et qui fasse ça je faisais
des crobars ensuite j'avais un long
moment avec le maqueettiste David MAE
dis voilà je voudrais un truc qui fasse
comme ça comme ça comme ça et je
voudrais qu'à ce momentlà ça monte parce
que je vais expliquer ça il faudrait
qu'à côté il y ait un truc comme ça
enfin bon ça se passait voilà ça
seoulait comme ça une une réunion
maquette comme on disait et puis ensuite
David faisait de de jolis crobar sur un
cahier belles aquarelles et et il me
montrait la maquette et je disais ouais
c'est ça mais alors non plutôt ça metle
plutôt par là et là tu vois bouge ça et
puis ensuite il y avait la phase il
fabriquait les maquettes avec son talent
de maquettiste j'allais aussi vérifier
la maquette voir si ça correspondait
bien à à ce qu'on voulait et puis le
jour du tournage il avait toujours des
retouches alors ça je fait pendant tout
seul pendant 4 5 ans au début et puis
après il y a il y a Emmanuel Pernau je
cite son nom qui est un des réalisateurs
aujourd'hui du du du monde de Jamie
voilà avec qui je travaille toujours
main dans la main et qui est venu me
seconder les maquettes d'ailleurs qui
étaient renforcé avec les petits sonores
on a tous dans notre tête fonctionn
exact et et du coup je me suis posé une
question après un peu plus tard dans ma
vie de me dire ça pouvait pas être tout
tout automatisé des fois y avoir
quelqu'un de caché qui pousse c'est un
truc qui tirait une langanguette qui il
y avait le fameux Marcel c'est génial
Marcel était sous l'établi parce que
mais c'est pour ça que quand on pensait
à la maquette on pensait aussi à sa
conception et oui on était là avec David
en train de se dire alors attends on va
la mettre comme ça sur l'établi mais il
va falloir que que alors on l'appelait
Marcel c'était pas son son son son vrai
prénom mais il va falloir que Marcel
soit soit dessous on va tirer une
languette et à ce moment-là on va
injecter l'eau avec cette seringue
parfois il y avait trois personnes sous
l'établi en train manipuler des aimentss
tiré des languettes tirés sur des
ficelles c'est pire que guignol de
l'info avec les marionnettes
complètement mais c'était c'était génial
alors ce qui ce qui veut dire que
c'était c'était des tournages qui
étaient longs parce que il fallait que
tout fonctionne oui c'est une
chorégraphie là après en même temps et
que les caméras soient là au bon moment
que je ne me plante pas dans le texte et
que tout c'était une chorégraphie est-ce
que c'est déjà arrivé un gros raté sur
une maquette ah ben il y en a eu plein
il y en a eu plein mais bon comme
l'émission n'était pas en direct on
recommençait oui évidemment j'avais
entendu parler mais peut-être que je me
trompe d'un problème de température qui
avait eu oui oui absolument qui avait
fait remettre en cause un peu tout tout
à fait on avait fait une émission sur
sur l'air on avait plein d'expérience
parce qu'on faisait quand même pas mal
de manip et et on aimait bien que comme
tu l'as dit il y avait beaucoup de
choses qui bougeaient dans tous les sens
mais moi j'aimais bien quand quand la
manip se se se
se se concrétisait grâce à
des phénomènes naturels quand on Fa des
choses avecau je voulais que ce soit
l'eau que j'utilise qui soit à l'origine
du phénomène et avec l'air on avait tout
ce qu'il nous fallait
puisque
évidment sauf que c'était au mois de
janvier que toutes les manipes on les
avait testé avec David dans son atelier
où il faisait 14 deg alors que sur le
plateau en fin de journée il faisait
plutôt 30 de tout avait été pour ça et
ça fonctionnait très bien à 14°gr mais à
30 ça ne marchait pas donc voilà donc il
a fallu refaire c'est un tournage qui
avait dû se terminer aux alentours de 2
3h du matin tu m'éton sur les genoux du
coup sur tous les sujets que tu as
traité tu tu traites avec la passion de
traiter des sujets de les faire
découvrir mais est-ce que il y a des
sujets dont tu t'es pris de passion toi
littéralement oui mais il y en a un il y
a le volcanisme on a fait notre première
émission sur les volcans euh sur en
Sicile sur l'thna j'étais dans le camion
et de temps en temps sortait hein de la
remorque et donc j'accompagner Fred sur
le terrain et et ça a été une révélation
on a eu la chance d'assister au réveil
de l'ethna avec des volcanologues et
d'être aux premières loges et quand je
dis aux premières loges euh quand l'Etna
s'est réveillé on a attendu parce que
des scientifiques nous disaient qu'il
allait se réveiller au début il nous
disait dans quelques jour et puis ça
finit ça s'est transformé par demain et
par non je pense que ce soir il va se
passer quelque chose et de fait à 11h on
nous a appelé on on dînit dans un un une
tratoria à quelques kilomètres de de de
de l'Etna 11h30 il m'appelle en dit on
passe vous prendre ça démarre on est
monté en 44 et puis on voyait au-udessus
de nos têtes parce qu'il faisait nuit le
début de l'éruption alors ça faisait des
espèces de de comme un feu d'artifice à
des des des grosses boules qui sortaient
de mais c'est c'était c'était assez
régulier au début et puis on est allé se
poster au pied du cratère on était à 500
m du cratère les vent était dans le bon
sens il ne venit pas vers nous ils étai
il partaient dans l'autre sens je me
souviens de c'était les propos du
scientifique qui me dit du volcanolog
qui me dit on est à 500 m du cratère le
cratère fait 500 m de hauteur et au
moment du paroxisme de l'éruption
c'estàd quand la fontaine de lave
atteint son maximum et bien la fontaine
faisait 500 m de hauteur elle aussi
incroyable voilà ça veut dire dire que à
cette distance et bien on on on sent
l'odeur du du souffre l'odeur de la
roche chaude ça a une odeur particulière
sent la chaleur ça a
duré jusqu'à 5h du matin et c'était
merveilleux et à partir de ce jour ben
j'ai adoré les volcans et et depuis j'en
ai fait pas mal j'en ai visité pas mal
question piège est-ce que la science
c'est une croyance plus ça va plus on
lit des personnes dans des échanges sur
Internet qui a jamais autant donné la
parole on a jamais eu une agora telle
des gens qui disent oui benah la science
c'est ta croyance est-ce que c'est ta
croyance la science non il y a les
croyances et puis il y a la science qui
repose sur des basses qui n'ont rien à
voir alors c'est vrai que dans notre
vocabulaire en français notamment dans
notre façon de parler on dit souvent je
crois que il faut redonner le sens au
croire au moment où un scientifique
dit je je je crois qu'il y a de la vie
ailleurs c'est pas voilà c'est pas une
croyance il ne le dit pas en suggérant
la même chose que lorsqu'il dit je crois
en Dieu s'il croit voyez donc il faut
vraiment analyser le propos et c'est pas
parce qu'on a dit je crois que
on place la science sur le plan de la
croyance surtout pas ça n'a rien à voir
on peut croire en certaines choses mais
la science ce n'est pas une croyance une
croyance elle s'appuie
sur culture sur pensée peut-être une
philosophie la science elle s'appuie sur
des faits sur une méthode sur des
démonstrations et des démonstrations qui
ne reposent pas sur la citation d'un
auteur suffit pas de dire un tel a dit
que pour que ce soit vrai non il faut
que nimporte qui puisse reproduire la
même expérience dans la même condition
on montre que l'expérience se reproduit
dans les mêmes conditions mais qu'elle
ne se reproduit pas dans d'autres
conditions oui c'est la méthode
scientifique la science peut aussi
émettre des hypothèses mais attention
l'hypothèse Estelle aussi argumentée à
faire ben moi mon hypothèse c'est que là
dans la pièce il y a un fantôme alors là
par contre c'est vrai
voilà non mais tu vois on peut pas faire
des hypothèses surt c'estàd que si si
sinon il y a plus de de de débat
possible et et et c'est ce qui est très
important j'entends aussi parfois quand
on est dans un débat comme ça où
s'oppose des vérités à des croyances des
gens qui disent oui mais ça ça c'est ce
que dit la science non la science si
elle le dit c'est que ça a
été prouvé oui elle dit pas elle établit
en fait dit pas absolument c'est c'est
c'est c'est un fait voilà qui est avéré
et et qui a été avéré en adoptant une
méthode particulière que tous les
scientifiques adoptent sinon on ne peut
plus parler de la même chose on ne peut
plus parler il n'y a plus de débat
possible par que même moi tu es en train
de me débloquer quelque chose une espèce
de fatigue de la loi de Brandolini où
puisqu'on a le droit d' éblir toutes les
hypothèses possibles bah du coup c'est à
l'autre de devoir redémontrer que son
hypothèse est scientifique mais c'est
très fatiguant parce que c'est beaucoup
plus long de redémontrer que toi c'est
pas une hypothèse et c'est la science
que la personne qui va exprimer son tout
et n'importe
quoi comme ça c'est quoi en quelques mot
ce qui t'a donné envie d'ouvrir la
chaîne épicurieux alors encore une fois
le hasard le hasard fait beaucoup de
choses s'il y avit pas eu le confinement
je pense que si j'aurais peut-être fait
quelque chose ch mais pas comme ça
ouais mais d'un seul coup j'ai
mesuré j'ai mesuré la force de de de de
ce média j'étais pas tellement sur les
réseaux auparavant peut-être à tort
d'ailleurs mais un petit peu quand même
pour me rendre compte je suivais
quelques personnes je je me suis rendu
compte que que c'était c'était un un
média un champ qu'il fallait
absolument investir pour transmettre du
savoir parce que c'est là où se trouve
aujourd'hui une grande partie du public
aujourd'hui encore j'entends j'entends
beaucoup de de j'entendais encore un
débat à la radio hier où euh on
remettait en question euh les réseaux
euh tout ce qui se disait sur les
réseaux mais à aucun moment on a dit
mais vous savez que sur les réseaux il y
a aussi des gens
qui donnent des infos justes vérifier et
qui font un vrai travail de journaliste
il y a des journalistes sur les réseaux
qui donne ces informations parce que on
ne pourra pas échapper au réseau bien
sûr on ne pourra pas échapper alors il y
a deux solutions ou bien euh on dit
c'est pas bien on critique on laisse ce
champ libre à tous ceux qui disent des
bêtises ou bien on investit ce champ
pour être aussi fort que ceux qui disent
des bêtises c'est quoi la dernière chose
que tu as prise il y a il y a 8 jours on
est en train de préparer une émission
sur euh les menaces qui pèsent sur la
mer Méditerranée et on était à Banuls
avec des scientifiques qui bossent sur
les les plastiques dans dans dans dans
les océans moi j'étais persuadé que bah
voilà les bouteilles de plastique
arrivaient dans l'océan et puis étaient
broyés puis ça devenait des
microplastiques en fait ce que j'ai
appris c'est que quand les les
microplastiques qui arrivent dans dans
l'océan et bien en fait ils sont déjà
l'état de microplastique quand ils
arrivent VO en fait ce sont des des des
des plastiques qui très souvent sont
sont jetés dans la nature qui finissent
dans les cours d'eau et c'est dans les
cours d'eau qu'ils vont être dégrade
transformé à cause de de de tout un tas
de de de de de phénomènes et c'est là où
il y a une transformation et quand ils
arrivent dans les océans et bien ils
sont déjà en l'état de microplastique ce
qui rend d'ailleurs leur prélèvement
très compliqué parce qu'on pourrait dire
bah dans ce cas on va mettre des filtres
au niveau des des des des filets au
niveau de de de l'embouchure des des des
des des fleuves c'est pas possible parce
que ces microplastiques font très
souvent la taille des des des planctons
phyoplanctons ou zooplancton qui
viennent qui sont la première étape de
la source de N et voilà et qui viennent
des rivières donc si on mettait des
filet B on va tout bloquer on va tout
bloquer donc voilà ça c'est une chose
que que que que j'ai apprise j'ai ce que
je voulais je voulais avoir ton œil qui
pétile et le sourire de je viens de
découvrir ça oui de comprendre c'est
c'est merveilleux merveilleux merci pour
t temp et ta générosité Jamie merci
Fabien merci
[Musique]
beaucoup